>> So this is a remarkable fact about this Q-learning
rule, and that is if we start Q hat off
pretty much anywhere, and then we update it according to
the rule that we talked about. Q for, for when
we see a transition s,a, r, s prime, then we
update (s,a), the Q value for (s,a), move it alpha
of the way towards r plus gamma, max a of
the, well basically the Q value of the state S prime.
Then as long as we do that, then this estimate, this q hat S A
goes to Q S A. The actual solution to the Bellman equation. And I write
this with an exclamation mark, because it's
like, it's one line of code! It's one
line of code, like, how could you not just go out and write this right now?
>> Hm.
>> But the, the, the, let me just, to finish is, this is only true if we
actually visit SA infinitely often. So you know, that's an important caveat.
That for this to, to actually hold true, for you to really converge
to the, the solution, it has to run for a long time. It
has to visit all state action pairs. The learning rates have to be
updated the way that we talked about before. The next states need to
be drawn from the actual transition probabilities but that's, that's cool, if we
actually are learning in some actual environment and the rewards need to be
drawn from the rewards function. So, this isn't so problematic. This is a
little bit problematic, but it is still very reassuring, this idea that we have
the right form of an update rule, so that the thing
that we converge to is the actual optimal solution to the MDP.
>> Cool. And we just have to wait til the
heat death of the universe, or infinity, and then we're done.
>> Yeah.